[Applause]
thank you all
so much thank you for those uh joining
us at home
by the riverbanks and thank you for
those in the room
when i think of lila i hum
in the room where it happens uh that's
my version
of hamilton's uh the moment where
hamilton is
whisked into the room with jefferson and
david burr is stuck
outside feeling like he is not in the
room where it's all happening
and the reason i hum it when i think of
lyla is i think of all the times that
people feel shut out
of ai and i'm so glad
that not only is lila in that room but
she's also trying to help other people
get into that
room and uh that is why i'm thrilled
that you're here with me today the ceo
of deepmind
recently moved to london just before
lockdown
and really her life could fill a
blockbuster
movie um so i thought we could start
there
what i would love to know is what do you
think
ten-year-old lyla would think of where
you are today
well that is quite the question for the
first time of an in-person
uh meeting too so hello everyone uh here
in the room and online and thank you
tabitha for having me
it's interesting uh question to start
with because
actually my 10 year old self was
the odd one out um i was the
darkest kid in my school i spoke with
an arabic accent in the middle of the
united i was in the midwest in the
united states
um and so i got very comfortable i was
being the odd one out
and my 10 year old self had very high
ambitions
i was going to run for president of the
united states
because i spent most of my time
discussing and fighting with about
politics with my teachers
even at that age what was interesting
was if just a few years later i ended up
in japan as an exchange student
i was 16 in a city of 40 000 people
and i was suddenly the american so no
longer was i the odd person
in america but i was the american in
this town
and so and so i think i've got very used
to being
the unusual one from such a young age
yeah it doesn't feel so unusual now at
least at least you've been in london
for a little bit longer well and the
benefit of black down is i've actually
gotten to know my way around a little
bit more
um because we haven't been able to
travel outside of the country
and tell us a little bit you started
your career at intel how did that feel
how long were you there for tell us a
little bit about that journey
great well um i studied electrical
engineering in university
um one of the very few women uh in the
program
in fact we used to carry our resistors
and capacitors in little tackle box
fishing tackle boxes
so i was known as the the girl with the
purple tackle box
and i actually landed a job at intel in
1990 and i was the first
person from my university to ever do an
intern program
with um with intel so i ended up after
graduation going back and spending 18
years at intel
seven of which were six of which were in
asia
it started off as a microprocessor
engineer
and then realized that i didn't want to
be working on a small part of a small
chip
so ended up working more with customers
in terms of helping to do the technical
development
and then move my way up the the
value chain of like then doing the
deployment of how do you build computers
and servers and
infrastructure and then actually how do
you get those in the hands of people
and communities worldwide a lot of times
for the very first time that they had
um countries and communities had access
to
technology one of the things we
discovered is the computers
wasn't good unless it was connected to
the internet so we suddenly had to
figure out how to get
internet out into some developing
economies
and then get the communities trained up
and using them
so it was a pretty exciting adventure
but after 18 years at intel
and doing such incredible work from an
engineer
up to chief of staff of the company
decided that i was ready to
go find something else and i had learned
that i was an entrepreneur i was inside
of a large company
doing entrepreneurial type of work but i
could take big risks because we had the
balance sheet and i wondered what it was
like
on the other side what was it like on
the other side
well um i went to venture capital yeah
and
because it was uh you know coming from a
big company i wasn't quite ready to be
an entrepreneur and
that's just not me i partner well with
entrepreneurs but
i was interested in knowing what it was
like to be in a small company so i went
to venture capital where i got an
amazing insight
to see how audacious and exciting and
passionate and visionary entrepreneurs
and i guess you could then give them the
balance sheet to be to take those risks
exactly and also the training like how
do you build a company
and how do you think about having
development conversations with employees
and how do you set
goals objectives and key results how do
you manage
your p l yeah so yeah all sorts they
come to you with ideas and
you realize you break it down into
actually what the uh what the real
challenge is
and then i think someone lured you out
of venture capital into their own
startup
yes i was who was that um i was
uh i'm passionate i have a passion for
education
and uh we can talk about that if you're
interested but i definitely will
um i got asked to go in to work with the
founders of a company called coursera
has anybody here worked with coursera
lots of nodes no that's great thank you
um so i was the first i helped make the
investment in coursera
and then joined when the company was
about 40 people
and as the president and uh as
co as we grew the organization so
started up a lot of the
efforts around how to work with
companies how to work with
marketing how to start up marketing um
how to manage the budget
the opera internal operations codifying
the values with the founders
so quite a range of things and i i was
there
from our you know our base got our first
million in revenue
uh um and about 40 people all the way up
to over 300 people
through the series d and then decided i
had
done what i wanted to do in terms of
build helping to build and enable the
company
and the platform to serve millions of
learners worldwide
and decided after so long of a career
and being kind of pulled into taking
different roles i was actually going to
take a year off
yeah nice how was that yeah what did you
do
someone gave me great advice they say
however much time you think you're going
to take
double it if you're ambitious because
you're you'll always find things to keep
yourself busy
so um i got asked by someone uh
on the alphabet board yeah to talk to
demis who is the founder and
ceo at what point of your year was that
two months in two months in yeah
see they say that about maternity leave
as well yeah triple what you think
you're gonna do
two months in you met dennis how was
tell me what did you think the first
time you met him
well i was before i met him i was like
i'm
really neat this year i really need this
time because actually when i had uh
gave birth to my twins that's when i
moved from intel to
uh venture capital so i never really had
a proper
proper break so i was convinced i was
not going to
want to go to deepmind or to like dumas
and then i kept postponing the meeting
and they're finally like listen if
you're open to this and it's
middle of winter and i talked to him
first by video
oh my god darn it i really like this
like really fascinated by this guy
and i also thought um if i wanted to do
ai i would stay in silicon valley
why move to london especially in the
middle of winter
yeah and i
really tried not to
the more i learned including a january
visit for my first
in-person interview january visit well
done london
yeah we did a good job i mean mainly
demis but i'll still take that
it was great i actually took about 50
hours interviewing
yeah because for me i wanted to be
convinced
if i was going to move my family over
here that it was the right move
and candidly the more that i learned
about the mission of deep mind
i thought this is pretty audacious and
the responsibility
of it felt really significant
and i thought can i put my daughters to
sleep at night and know that
i mommy worked on this technology and
made a positive impact with it so it
felt
um very i felt a moral calling in the
end
to move over and to take this and it was
i tell
everybody it was i'm exactly where i'm
supposed to be
my career has prepared me for this role
what a lovely feeling
and i do actually think that's probably
a good moment to tell everybody
because they might not actually know
what is deep mind's mission
vision i was going to actually tell the
world at the beginning of the intro and
i think i forgot i was too excited to
ask you questions
i was enjoying your singing exactly
that's what happens when you sing
um tell us briefly what is the mission
for d mind
our goal is to solve intelligence
to advance science and humanity
pretty good huh and then it's the mic
drop right
that you're all told to do that after
you've said it i'm sure and i think
that's a
really good uh you know good mission i'm
not surprised you felt it was a calling
so you'd met demis the calling happened
you arrived in the uk what does it feel
like to arrive at a company with a
mission like that and a
a lead business and be the ceo like
you're here to
to do all those things you described
that you were helping people understand
that kind of perkins but
what do you do now yeah and i think the
ceo role is very interesting because
it's different in every organization
based on where the organization is at
and who the
executive team about the executive team
and the founders
and what i i had spent enough time doing
my own diligence
on deepmind and the team that i actually
felt like i was
ready to get started
but you know one of the things about
founders is they have these amazing
visions and they've built something
from scratch and deepmind had done an
amazing job i was the company's first
i am the company's first ceo and
so how do you understand it's almost you
come in as an ethnographer
and you try to understand how did this
organization
how did this technology get developed
what is special and different
and where do we need to go so that we
build forward
with purpose versus i think coming in
and feeling like i needed to change
things
so figuring out how to operationalize
the vision was actually
the biggest challenge and then it was
really interesting too because in london
i commute one of the buildings nearby
and
i walk by the fashion school on the tube
i see
the posters of all the theater and
it's very different than silicon valley
when you're driving down the highway
and you learn about the latest cloud
storage
and data back-end infrastructure so
suddenly you're just reminded on a
day-to-day basis about
the diversity the human humanity culture
the arts and you bring that into work so
it was very much of the first actually
even like six months of just being
kind of this how do you understand and
appreciate
what's here so you can build it right
and in partnership with the founders
and sort of absorb that feeling i i
walked through and
all the kids are outside with the with
water spraying you kind of can't build
things
in that environment that could
potentially harm those
that that lovely version of of the
reality of the world it's amazing
so how do you foster a culture then that
also agrees with you and does
feel that when engineering typically
isn't the most as you described in
silicon valley feeling
you know feeling uh business well
and i'm not an ai expert in fact when
our machine learning expert when um deep
mind approached me i said
you do realize like i have a hardware
engineering background and
um i've done a lot of infrastructure but
not on the
computer science side and actually i
think that in many ways appealed
to the organization because i could
bring that perspective in
so one of the things that i found in in
my career and in fact we as i mentioned
we've
i've seen technologies take hold in
communities
or see companies go through technology
transformations before
and the first thing is to get the people
around the table
so one of the things that i was able to
do i feel
very privileged like i said i had a
moral calling and the fact that i could
actually help
i never thought i'd actually help get
stuff set up like that but
we set up a multi-stakeholder like
within the organization
people from different parts of the
organization at different levels
in within the organization to come
together to talk about some of our
research now deepmind's research is very
advanced
um and we work on the fundamental
research that
we don't necessarily take and put it
into the market so how can we
have the conversations about what might
those risks be
how are we responsible um do we have
ideas on solutions should we be funding
alternative solutions um so
being able to have those conversations
in a psychologically safe environment
and really challenge each other
and then be able to bring in um expert
panels
and expertise when we don't have it so
we're very conscious of our inside our
bias
yeah so that's one thing for example but
we have a team of ethicists
and we have a team of social scientists
we work on technical safety
and it's not just within deep mind but
we also work with fellow travelers
yeah others in the um in the industry
who also are working maybe on adjacent
areas or similar areas where we can
exchange ideas even share
what type of work we're doing so that we
can learn from each other
one of the areas i'm most i'm quite
excited about is
our social um socio-technical research
recently published a couple of papers
one was on um uh
with the lgbtqi plus lens
around queer fairness looking at
implications of on ethics and fairness
and another was on the colonial ai so
looking at the
colonial implications on ai so
bringing some of these sensitive topics
to the forefront and having real
conversation to ensure that
what we are doing is is in a responsible
way at least in as much as the
information we have at the time yeah and
i think that's what's
that's what's always been it drawn me so
much deep mind is that you don't shy
away from those conversations
if you're looking to solve intelligence
that in itself is a colonial
challenge so um i always think that and
then
you know a few weeks later i hear do you
mind writing something about this and
there's a paper coming out it's a really
it's
it's a good place and i guess that's why
i do um you know
hum that song is because that's what we
need you know the ecosystem and
as a fellow traveler that's exactly what
we're looking for and actually if i
don't if you don't mind
one of the things that we also do is we
encourage our staff
deepminders as they're called we
encourage them to participate in
industry activities so whether it's
chairing conferences
we had one of our research scientists
chair the world's largest
mlai conference called eurips last year
and one of the requirements for the
first time in the conference history was
to as part of the paper submission
including a statement about the societal
and ethical implications of the work
we also just had another research
scientist william isaac chairs
a conference on fairness uh fairness and
as
people here may not know tabitha and i
work together on the
ai council which she chairs which helps
to
provide guidance to uh the uk government
on matters related to ai
yeah we're so we're we're so lucky i
think
um that that is a decision because it
definitely wasn't an early decision for
deepmind so it's been so nice to see now
everywhere you go there will be somebody
from people have chosen themselves to do
that and
across the festival you can see lots of
deep minders uh doing their own sessions
for i think that reason exactly and it
makes a real difference
tell everyone how do you choose what you
are going to direct this power at
so you know you solve intelligence and
then you decide what you're going to
point it to
i mean that is just the biggest
questions
what's the the criteria the process by
which you go about
uh it's interesting it's almost like
venture capital where you have
this resource and you say you know
they're in and the secret is there's no
magic checklist yet
also with venture capital making
investments i think
within deep mind and one of the things
i've learned in my career
is when you have put really smart people
together they're very creative and they
know the power of what they're working
on the passion and so what happens is
they come up with incredible ideas so we
have done
all sorts of activity research efforts
but where we're predominantly trying to
focus is on understanding
we call it the root nodes of science so
the
the general philosophy is if we can
truly go back to our mission
solve intelligence to advance humanity
science and humanity
what does it take to have ai as a tool
to unlock new areas of science that
industries can be built on that world's
problems can be
solved so one of those i'm quite excited
about
is called our is our alpha fold yeah
which is our advanced
ai system um may i ex please
i was just going to ask you two and i
was just checking
whether i was allowed by myself please
tell us about
evolve great thanks um so
uh pro protein proteins protein folding
has been a grand challenge of the
structural biology community
for half a century basically if you can
predict how proteins fold how
the 3d structures are based on their
genetic sequence
then you can unlock answers to all sorts
of problems that depend on protein so
for example
maybe understanding diseases how do
proteins how does a protein going to
fold or misfold
and that could provide insights or
what and which enzymes can break down
industrial waste
so there's all sorts of unexpected
magical things about protein protein
[Music]
so the uh industry and sometimes people
will spend like an entire phd trying to
work on just
one protein so we've uh
been able to pull together a very
diverse set
of scientists biologists physicists
chemists
combined with ethicists and engineers
and built an ai system
that that is built off the
half century of experimentation and
knowledge
and it's basically the alpha fold system
can help
to predict how a protein will fold
now um we'll be publishing a paper
on this later this year in a
peer-reviewed journal and with that
hopefully be able to unlock a lot for
others too to build off in terms of
understanding disease and
waste management and all sorts of other
exciting things
and i think that that's i mean we that
in a moment i'm going to come
in about 10 minutes in case anyone has
any questions but for now i'm going to
keep hogging the floor um but do think
up some of your questions
um and that's what i think is is
interesting exciting about artificial
intelligence is you're going to make the
breakthrough
and then you're going to open this up so
that other people can use it
what are the other really big
opportunities that you can provide
the ai can provide but also that deep
mind can provide by
sort of leading the pack in making these
breakthroughs
well i would like to think that um it's
not just what we're developing
yeah but how we're developing it so this
multi-disciplinary approach um
being very thoughtful about the
downstream implications around
ethics and fairness and responsibility
um
at the end of the day we are focused on
this like long term
it is a very you know it is a long-term
mission with a lot of responsibility
and it is kind of um the way that we
culturally that we
were structured is it's the best of
academia the best of a
industry research lab kind of combined
with our own
special sauce so it's not just what we
do but
how we do it yeah and what's the biggest
challenge in that so you've got
especially these multi-disciplinary
teams that's something that
i think is both brilliant i mean
literally how
clearly it should be but also it must be
quite difficult to manage all the
different types of people
how does that work yeah um
that first six months of being the
ethnographer was very valuable
because one of the um i think one of the
interesting things
that we've had to do is how do you
navigate putting
process in place in a way that is
lightweight and right size for the
organization
and instills consistency and fairness
across the organization as we're doing
it because it's such a diverse
set of individuals within the
organization so how can we come together
around our values and um frameworks to
do this
i also um you know getting clear up
front too
about uh where do we have strength and
where do we need to partner with the
outside
i think has been really good like where
are and this is the benefit maybe of
being a research organization
is we know where our strength lies and
it is not necessarily on the building
the product
so how do we then focus both with our
sister organization google
or with the um the research industry in
general to unlock this other
other areas yeah and and you bring up
your sister organization google i mean
they
definitely deal slightly differently
with their teams being able to say and
think
uh exactly what they want and they're
not a research organization
how how did that fit as you know family
i guess
what are the challenges there well um
this is where i think some of my
background of having spent 18 years in a
corporate environment
um having sat on public company boards
i'm just understanding that there's
always interesting
collaboration and dynamic we have
we have operational autonomy over
how we you know because when you're
trying to think about even how do you
reward or incentivize
researchers it's very different than
trying to get a product
or you know quarterly earnings and
things like that so um
i think from the very beginning of the
acquisition
it was very uh thought through and
collaborative and very supportive
and in fact when even when i joined this
was one of the areas demas also
and i spent a lot of time talking about
was there's a lot a lot of
synergy between the organizations and
also a lot of separation so how
what's the right balance and how to do
that yeah
yeah it can't be an easy it can't be
easy
but you seem to be doing it with your to
me it's just like standard business
and again this is i think i often talk
about being in the right place at the
right time and hopefully
being able to bring kind of decades
worth of experience into
yeah you know just you know i was on a
i'm on regular calls with
um off my google and alphabet uh
counterparts and it
just feels like uh it doesn't it just is
right
just as a good way of describing it and
uh dennis often talks about being part
of the process of writing the google's
ethical framework for example
yes um and we all in this audience at
least um know about what the risks are
of ai but is there
an area of the risks that you're the
most concerned about or that you spend
more of your time thinking about
well um there's two sides to that one is
thinking about the risk and the other is
thinking about
the opportunity yes and it is a healthy
tension right it's
very easy to get lost in risk and i
think having
um a lot of the experience i i had in
the
early days earlier days of the internet
and bringing it into
um a lot of times like we took um as an
example
and i'll answer your question if you
humour me a moment
we took uh we did some wireless
infrastructure in the middle of the
amazon rainforest
where we connected an island community
of a hundred thousand people
um to the nearest town which was 20
hours by
by boat and uh they're like well
this is going to displace schools and
teachers and what about our health care
everyone's just going to go to the big
city and instead we worked a lot with
the local community
to get um the local workers engaged and
connect
so they didn't have to go get a library
book
from 20 hours away but rather could have
some of that access
the teachers still played a critical
role the technology was the tool
yeah and so um i think a lot about
how do we make sure underrepresented
voices and or
the community is engaged in in how we
get to the right solution so
where are our blind spots how do we not
be so academic about things because
eventually you have to make a decision
you have to take risk
um so how do you take calculated risk
and then engage
others along the way so that they have a
voice in how ai gets developed
um so i think it's you know just myself
coming from this
um we haven't talked about it but my
sister has cerebral palsy so
i've just grown up in an environment
where
um you can easily there's tensions in
the system
yeah so i feel like i have acute
awareness of those and i just
want to make sure that we take all of
this into consideration and i feel
this is back to my own moral
responsibility and i'm just one employee
out of you know thousands so
i think that's and i think deepminders
kind of opt in for that as part of our
mission
and i think that's what's uh that's
what's so lovely is you know the
opportunity's so great
um especially within health care you're
definitely in the right country uh right
country for that
and you talk about making sure that you
know the
the the general public the community are
actually involved
in the building how do you do that
technically it's not the easiest thing
our ecosystem is grappling with it all
the time
what are the things that you can be
doing to make that happen well
um we partner with a lot of
organizations they ate a lovelace
institute i think the partnership for ai
that brings together
many companies on this topic rai council
as well
which i think quite excited shall we go
there
we are also surveying yeah as part of
the ai council just being
understanding that we have a
responsibility to represent the
community so
um also surveying folks to um chime in
and be part of the conversation but
i think it really starts with awareness
and education
so on the um awareness side
uh as when we launched our alpha fold
uh protein folding advanced ai system
we also did an explainer video which you
can find on our website
trying to make this complex biology
more understandable for everyone
including myself
i'm like it has to be so i can share
this with my parents
i can tell them what i do um also
education we're doing a lot to
engage uh stem in the
uh with some science fairs we've done it
with the royal society
as well and then we sponsor diversity
scholarships
too to try to bring those voices into
graduate programs and
so they can get whether in academia or
in
into industry in key positions to
influence the future
i mean i look at my my children
i think they are growing up tech
literate um
they're very fortunate um and
they are going to be the generation that
lives with
ai all around them so how can
regardless of what field they go into
how can they understand the power of the
technology and the responsibility to be
good shepherds of it yeah that is the
challenge you've got to kind of hold
both your parents watching the video and
your kids knowing
how different their understandings are
and if anyone would like to learn a
little bit more about that scholarship
um in about half an hour i think
matt woman and one of those deepmind
scholars are actually talking about the
scholarship um
the minister for digital so that would
be quite good
um and i think and we're going to come
to questions if anyone wants to put
their hands
up if they have a question i will come
to you excellent
um and you did mention i get
getting more people involved the ai
council so it is worth telling everybody
that we have
launched a survey so for those of you
who are kind of interested in what lyla
said
in the air ecosystem would like to be
closer to the ai ecosystem there is a
survey
on the alan trains website they kindly
hosted the survey
for us where you can give your feedback
and we'll be disseminating it and giving
it to the office for ai who are writing
the national ai strategy
so um as as i said we're definitely
trying to open up
um the the room a little bit more but
let's come to those questions could you
all put your hands up one more time okay
excellent we're gonna go blue trousers
first
yeah it's an excellent question the the
question just for
in case folks didn't hear so um was
about how do we
engage stakeholders who aren't already
within the ai ecosystem or
happen to happen to be in that
privileged position
in many ways it feels like ai has been
around forever and we should have all of
this figured out
but it wasn't that long ago that it went
through the ai winter where
um you know even when i was talking with
um demis and
and shane like they couldn't get funded
early on um it wasn't that long ago that
um it wasn't necessarily kind of the hot
hot topic
um as a result i think we are quite
early in the the journey
and uh we still have a responsibility um
so there are a lot of historical
trends that are followed similar to
where it takes quite a while to get
ramped up so we're learning from those
multi-stakeholder public-private
collaboration
the ai council is is one here in the uk
we also um both within deep mind and i
know google has done the same of like
working
to do education so we've had some of our
research scientists
do machine learning tutorials for
different government workers as well the
ai council is an
advisory group it's still early on the
regulatory side right you want to have
pragmatic and take the time to make sure
that
what we're doing across ai makes sense
and has mitigates risk but also isn't so
safe that stops innovation
um so i think we're very much in this
early stage um
and the and people are talking with each
other yeah do you i don't know if you
want to add anything
i think that's more your area of
expertise literally the the thing that
i'm trying to do the most
i think what lyla said is so right and
it's about helping them talk to each
other as well
and learning from each other and we had
um oliver down obviously
the secretary of state for dcms this
morning quasi-car tank um
for bayes uh matt walman and amanda
soloway and actually being able to have
that group conversation and you will be
able to talk to them i think makes more
different you actually
feel and they can see that what they
love the most is case studies of how
it's going to help
the people that they are trying to help
how it's going to actually to help the
british people and that's what's amazing
i think about deep mind stories is
they are tangible um case studies
of the value of artificial intelligence
so that that helps me whenever
i get a minister asking me i just go
straight to my locker of
really useful examples um we're gonna
have a question we put your hands up
again
we're going to go to you and then we'll
come to mr greenshirt
uh
but earlier you talked about uh
um yes
it's uh it's a actually quite a deep
personal
um
a question for me so the moral calling
of joining deep mind so
um throughout my career let's see in the
year 2000 i went back to the orphanage
where my father was raised in lebanon
and built a computer
lab because i wanted to say thanks for
my father
and um my dad ended up being an
electrical engineer who
designed heart pacemakers and it always
amazed me
that this orphan boy from the mountains
in lebanon saved millions of lives
through some technology he developed
that was like art math and science which
is
how i got into engineering throughout my
career
i've seen i've been at this intersection
of technology and social impact
and i had a conversation with one of the
deep mind founders
shane legg who we had
i'm an engineer i didn't take liberal
arts classes in university
but we had this conversation around
morals and ethics and
who is right to say that one group's
morals are better than the others and
what is
what was ethical in grecian times is
quite different than now
and it really uh it was a
and demo spent a lot of our time talking
about how do you develop
this technology safely because i kept
saying well you know
why uh i came from a silicon valley
attitude which is like okay
can we just get get this out faster and
what do you do to do it fast and it's
like okay we
we are purposefully slowing down even
the alpha fold
how do we do how do we release this in a
in an ethical way that
takes the risks into consideration and
um i knew that i didn't have the answers
but i i was awake at night
thinking about these questions uh how do
you develop this technology
um and and i don't i'm not gonna be the
one to develop it
um uh i know that i am the one who can
ask the questions and
engineering actually i am engineering
reports into me so i may not be able to
write the code with them
but i can ask the questions and i have
been very fortunate in my career to be
around
leaders who whether it was a ceo of
intel whether
it was um the the venture capitalist who
made the first investment in amazon and
google
like i've been around some pretty um
amazing leaders who've asked
really simple questions and i'll give
you a hint of what those questions
are why what are you trying to achieve
what might go wrong what haven't you
thought about that you should have
like sometimes it's those questions that
really matter and so
i felt like my um
i felt like i had something to
give and to ask as part of this journey
that's my simple simple answer but
um it's been it's been exciting and like
i said even
the diversity scholarships we've now
expanded to over 30 countries
um across europe middle east africa
north and south america
we just welcomed 50 cohorts so it's been
really
exciting to see not only what we're
doing in the here and now with our
research but how we're preparing the
next generation
totally totally thanks for investing
what is does intelligence change
generationally a little bit different
then and
therefore what should intelligence be
yes and actually um general intelligence
versus narrow intelligence
it's actually quite um uh
quite a complicated answer and i just
always assume that there was a single
you know black and white answer and it
turns out one of the the technical
co-founders of shane legg actually his
entire phd thesis is on what is general
intelligence
and so what we're trying to do at
deepmind is actually
develop ai systems that can be applied
across many different things so
for example uh versus just in one
like if i asked you how many chairs are
in this room you could do a kind of
what is it what is a chair then do some
quick math and you
you have an estimate um but if i said
um you know how many coffee
mugs are on white tables or that's still
that's a little more advanced now if i
said like walk
you know so being able to apply
different
knowledge um and so we've done so
as an example within deepmind and
there's a great movie called um
uh alphago if you haven't uh seen that
yet
but that was like really tuning up on
how to play
we you know how to play go but then
applying that same ai system to play
all two other two player games
right with no rules so it had to learn
on its own by giving
a reward system the bottom line is
it's a simple question with very
complicated answers
and everyone's definition is different
and what deepmind is doing which is very
different than a lot of ai companies is
we're trying to look at
general intelligence and it's for that
purpose of like
the protein folding example is a great
one you can't really
solve it with knowing what we know as
humans right now so can we take our
learnings from other systems that we've
developed and apply it into this
it's definitely a question to keep
asking and correlate your answers that
you get
um alex from selden um your question
continuation of the
discussion around the ai
regulation uh so how can you
coordinate that so that we have a
uh sort of uh
similar set or uh like a regulation in
east and west which
yes luckily lila doesn't have to
coordinate it but how could one
actually we spend a lot of our time
within the ai council actually having
these conversations yeah
and um where do you start and where do
you where do you aspire to
be and um i think what's interesting is
there is not a right answer so it's a
lot of conversation
and a lot of debate um which we actually
participate in um so i think this is
also
a good you know where where do you
cooperate where do you
compete where do you um share
like and how do you know that when
you're not um aligned
like be explicit about that so um and
i i think it's a it's going to be we're
still very early but
it is a very complicated topic and hot
topic
yeah definitely give your feedback to
the to the survey which the video should
play in a second so
one last question from me if
you were stranded on a desert island and
your job was left to someone else
what would your advice be to them
i asked i asked warren earlier and he
said keep the faith
i would say proceed with care and
um enjoy the adventure i love it thank
you so much proceed with care and enjoy
the adventure thank you very much
la la cielo of deepmind thank you very
much and those at home
[Applause]